-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden spoke
from the Oval Office tonight
in a prime-time address
and asked Congress to approve
$100 billion in emergency funds.
Well, good luck with that.
We can't even get Congress
to approve each other.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Congressman
Carlos Gimenez said yesterday
that his office
has received robocalls
encouraging them to vote
for Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan.
But then he remembered
he actually saved
Jordan's number as Scam Likely.
[ Laughter ]
A group of moderate
Republican lawmakers
are reportedly pushing
to temporarily empower
acting House Speaker
pro tem Patrick McHenry.
Oh, you mean this guy?
[ Gavel bangs loudly ]
The...
The congressman from Asgard?
[ Laughter ]
Are we sure the lectern
can handle it?
He slammed that thing like
they just canceled "Fraser."
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
That dude watches "Fraser."
[ Laughter ]
While leaving court yesterday,
former President Trump said
that he "probably
won't return this week"
because of an upcoming
golf tournament
at his Miami golf club.
And he doesn't want to miss it
because it's probably
the last time
it will be considered
his Miami golf club.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Kenya
was arrested recently
for allegedly
impersonating a lawyer
and winning dozens of lawsuits.
"I have the exact opposite
problem," said Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter ]
"Maybe I should
stop pretending!"
[ Laughter ]
In his upcoming biography,
Utah Senator Mitt Romney
criticizes former
Texas Governor Rick Perry
and says,
"Republicans must realize
that we have to have someone
who can complete a sentence."
Responded Perry,
"How dare?"
[ Laughter ]
The drugstore chain
Rite Aid announced yesterday
that it will close
at least 150 stores.
So the Rite Aid
I was in last week...
you're telling me
that was open?
[ Laughter ]
I should have paid somebody.
And finally, a couple recently
got married
during the 10-second pit stop
of a NASCAR race.
And this is embarrassing.
The honeymoon was even faster.
"I swear this never happens!"
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody!
We're off to the races!
[ Cheers and applause ]